stéphane john et savannah sakineh tapis
rouge et ambiance début xxème siècle
cent ans après son ouverture la civette
est aujourd'hui le plus ancien phare de
l'ue
[Musique]
[Rires]
jusqu'en 1988 la civette était un
bar-tabac denise et lancelot qui a
travaillé pendant vingt six ans avec son
mari et sa belle-mère lino ventura serge
gainsbourg alain delon ou jean paul
belmondo
ils ont tous passé la porte de l'asf est
déjà sur paul belmondo qui se trouvait à
tomber en panne juste devant il
descendait tourner un film dans le midi
quand vous avez beaucoup de jeunes qui
achètent des cigarettes et où donc sont
rentrés et puis l'ont vu sous steam est
alors oui mais ce démenti ces pauvres et
alors ils ont été cherché cherché de
riccione tout ça alors je disais on n'a
jamais vendu autant de petits carnets et
de stylos que ce jour là on essaie de se
faire tout l'après midi
aujourd'hui la relève est assurée par
ces deux quimpérois lui aussi travaille
en famille avec son frère et sa femme
depuis trois ans ils ont relooké
l'établissement tout en perpétuant son
âme
j'ai travaillé longtemps sur paris dans
des bistrots et je voulais je voulais
refaire vivre ça
dans l'entreprise qu'on a repris et je
voulais que la civette deviennent
vraiment le bistrot au style parisien on
a juste changé une couleur le rouge qui
fait qui fait penser vraiment au bistro
parisien
mais on voulait pas toucher au style de
du bistrot avec les du miroir et toutes
ces choses là les bulles miroir qu'on a
gardé la verrière qui est toujours
existence et puis un peu ce côté
les ardoises vraiment le côté de liste
robinson les miroirs la marquise de la
civette semble bien installée dans le
coeur des berruyers pour encore une
bonne centaine d'années